The Netflix fantasy series Cursed makes a
lot of changes to the classic Arthurian legend,
and raises a lot of new mysteries.
Here are some of the biggest questions which
are still left unanswered by the end of the
show's first season.
From the very beginning, Cursed lets us know
that Nimue is eventually doomed to sink into
a deep body of water while bleeding from multiple
arrow wounds.
During the closing minutes of the first season,
we finally see how that happens: While attempting
to save a wounded Merlin alongside Morgana,
Nimue is confronted by a bow and arrow-wielding
Sister Iris.
Iris ignores Nimue's pleas for mercy and fires
several arrows into her.
Despite Merlin's attempt to save her, Nimue
tumbles from the bridge, disappearing into
the churning waters below, and leaving the
sword of power abandoned on the bridge.
When last we see her, Nimue is sinking to
her supposed death, recalling the image that
opened the season.
However, despite all signs pointing to Nimue
dying, her role in the Arthurian legend as
the mystical Lady of the Lake indicates that
she'll survive... somehow.
Nimue showed herself capable of tremendous
magic throughout the course of the season.
Maybe Merlin will use his magic to save her,
or perhaps Nimue will save herself through
her own magic.
When Nimue realizes that Merlin is her biological
father, she finally understands why her mother
tasked her with bringing the sword of power
to him.
Even more pieces fall into place when Merlin
shows her the circumstances that led to her
own conception.
The two met when Nimue's mother Lenore healed
Merlin from something inside his chest that
was causing him pain.
She promptly cut him open to extract it, and
was shocked to pull out the very sword of
power that Nimue returns to him years later.
Merlin mentions that the sword was his once,
but never explains how it ended up inside
him.
The most he offers is that it wasn't an enemy
who did it, but beyond that, we never get
any information on what the sword was doing
inside Merlin's body.
Was he hiding it?
Was it a curse?
We may never know -- or at least, not by the
end of season one.
Merlin insinuates several times that he's
actually hundreds of years old, but we never
uncover the reason behind his staggeringly
long life.
Originally, Merlin was born into the Fey,
but his powers seem to exceed those of the
other Fey that we meet.
When we encounter Merlin in Cursed, he's been
without his magic for some time, and we later
learn that he lost his powers when Lenore
extracted the sword of power from his body.
Merlin spends most of the season endeavoring
to get his magic back through various methods,
and as he does, he winds up brushing against
death quite a few times.
At one point, after having been stabbed multiple
times through the chest, he even asks the
rhetorical question,
"Why can't I die?"
It's a good question.
Not only should his stab wounds have been
mortal, but he was shot in the heart with
an arrow earlier in the same episode.
We see plenty of other Fey die over the course
of Cursed, so what makes Merlin different?
Probably one of the biggest twists Cursed
throws at its audience comes when we learn
the true identity of the Weeping Monk that
has been terrorizing the Fey for the entire
season.
"Lancelot.
A long time ago my name was Lancelot."
The Weeping Monk's adopted father is Father
Carden, leader of the Red Paladins, who despise
the Fey and their magic.
But midway through the series, Gawain the
Green Knight recognizes the Weeping Monk as
a fellow Fey.
By the end of the season, the Weeping Monk
has turned on his adopted father, saving the
young Fey boy, Squirrel.
Yet the reveal that the Monk was actually
named Lancelot before he was taken by Father
Carden still comes as quite a shock.
Carden tells Lancelot that he spared him from
the slaughter of his village because of his
ability to sense other Fey, but considering
Carden's track record, we can't believe that
that's the complete story.
We're curious to learn more about the young
Lancelot before Carden took him.
While Cursed is up front about the identities
of legendary characters such as Merlin and
Arthur, it enjoys doling out the more famous
names of other characters throughout the course
of the season.
On several occasions, characters we've met
under one name reveal that their actual name
is much more familiar.
"Igraine was my grandmother's name.
Bit of a mix-up when they first brought me
here.
To friends, I'm Morgana."
"Go, Squirrel!"
"I won't leave you here."
"Percival!"
It begs the question of whether there are
any other well known Arthurian characters
who have already made an appearance, but under
different names.
Since Cursed plays pretty fast and loose with
the characters' backstories, we can't rule
anyone out.
After all, if the chivalrous knight Lancelot
can be introduced as one of the season's most
terrifying villains, anything is possible.
Perhaps Sister Iris or Pym will eventually
turn out to be familiar characters from the
legend, or a minor character will turn out
to be much more mythologically important than
we'd thought.
Something about Iris has always seemed a little
strange, starting with her first meeting with
Nimue, where Iris reveals how she can spot
demons.
"I just stare at them.
I stare at them until I see through their
faces to their real faces."
It's clear that Iris and Nimue are likely
not going to be friends, and sure enough,
Iris is soon burning down the abbey and attempting
to find the Red Paladins, determined to join
their bloody cause by killing Nimue.
But while Iris is certainly motivated by a
strong hatred of the Fey and their magic,
there seems to be more to her than that.
Several times, she seems to be internally
conflicted about the path she's set for herself,
and at one point, she punishes herself for
straying from her task by burning her own
arm over an open flame, berating herself as
though she's of two minds.
Between her radical hatred, her unflinching
capacity for violence, and her strange internal
debates, we wonder if there's a lot more to
Sister Iris than meets the eye.
When Nimue asks Merlin about the sword of
power, he admits that it was once his, and
that at one time, he might have desired it
again.
However, he claims his motives have since
changed.
"Let me destroy it."
"What?"
"That's my true intention, if you must know
it."
It turns out Merlin did want the sword back
almost immediately after Lenore extracted
it from his chest, since he realized the sword
was tied to his magic.
At the time, Lenore lied and told him that
she had destroyed the sword.
But by the time he learns that Nimue is his
daughter, he seems to have experienced a true
change of heart, and seems sincere about destroying
the sword.
Yet, by the end of the season, Merlin's magic
has returned, and it seems to be tied directly
to his reclaiming of the sword.
The last we see of him, he survives only by
channeling the sword's magic.
Will he still be committed to destroying the
sword, now that he's had a taste of its power
again?
We'll have to wait to find out.
Nimue may be the character who spends the
most time with the sword of power, but Merlin
has the longest history with the magical object.
The first indication of Merlin's connection
to the sword came when he was struck by lightning
and branded with a sword-shaped burn mark
that ran the length of his body.
Later, we learned that the sword was at one
time Merlin's, that it somehow wound up embedded
inside his body, and that his magic is somehow
linked to it.
Yet for every small detail we do know, there's
plenty we don't.
Where did the sword come from before it came
into Merlin's possession, and how did it get
so strongly linked to him?
What is the source and extent of its magical
abilities?
For an object that was at the center of most
of the conflicts in Cursed's first season,
we actually know very little about it, and
are eager to learn more.
Midway through Cursed's first season, King
Uther Pendragon receives a rude awakening
when he learns that he is not, in fact, royal
by birth as he'd always assumed.
It turns out that when his mother was pregnant
with her son, complications in childbirth
led to the baby being delivered stillborn.
The king had just died several months prior,
and desperate for an heir, the queen sent
her midwife out to pay a local peasant to
give up her baby.
The midwife returned the baby to the queen,
who raised him as her own.
Uther learns that his biological mother was
named Sylvia, and that she died shortly after
giving up her child, at the age of only 19.
Enraged, Uther poisons the queen with spiced
wine, which is the same method she used to
kill Sylvia.
However, as far as we know, Sylvia was the
only member of his family ever killed as part
of the queen's cover-up, which means his father
may still be out there, somewhere, along with
other members of his family.
Will he go seeking them, or will they eventually
track him down?
We'll have to wait and see.
Once the truth of Uther's illegitimacy begins
to come to light, the Viking ruler Cumber
the Ice King arrives with a claim to the throne.
Although Cumber claims to have Pendragon lineage,
it is never clarified exactly what his relationship
to the late king was.
The most we learn is when the midwife gives
Cumber a blood-soaked cloth, presumably from
the queen's stillbirth.
"This is the blood of my cousin?"
"It is, my lord."
Perhaps his use of the word "cousin" means
that Cumber was the king's nephew.
However, "cousin" could also be a broader
term referring to any distant relative, in
which case Cumber's bloodline could have diverged
with the Pendragons several generations earlier.
It will be interesting to see whether the
connection between Cumber and the Pendragons
is explored further in future seasons, and
exactly what that connection is.
Many times throughout Cursed, Uther seems
to refer to himself in the plural, using pronouns
like "we" and "our" to express his thoughts
and opinions.
"Tear us down, and you will suffer as we suffer."
There doesn't appear to be much rhyme or reason
to when he uses plural pronouns, and when
he refers to himself as "I," begging the question
of what exactly is going on here.
Maybe Uther is referring to either his kingdom
or his court when he speaks in the plural,
but that doesn't feel like what is happening.
At times, it almost seems like there may be
multiple consciousnesses warring inside him.
Yet no one ever seems to blink at his fluid
oscillation between singular and plural pronouns,
suggesting that either no one notices, or
everyone has just accepted it as a strange
quirk.
We have to wonder who Uther is referring to
whenever he says "we," and if we'll ever learn
any more about them.
The mysterious, shrouded character known only
as "the Widow" appears in a handful of episodes
to warn characters that death may be swiftly
approaching.
While it's obvious that the Widow has one
foot in the world of the living, and the other
in the world of the dead, very little is ever
communicated about her own identity.
Some sort of shared history with Merlin is
hinted at, but no real detail is ever given.
Adding another intriguing layer to the mystery
of the Widow is that she's not actually immortal.
Morgana actually manages to kill her off screen
toward the end of season one, and subsequently
takes her place.
Even Morgana herself isn't entirely sure how
it happens, but her becoming the new Widow
suggests that the previous Widow was also
once someone else entirely.
Was she someone Merlin knew?
How did she become the Widow?
And who was the Widow before her?
We'll just have to hold out hope that Cursed
gets a second season, so we can find out.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.